let's start with the biggest question
who is God according to Islam
God is
the most compassionate the most merciful
the creator of the heavens and the Earth
he is one God
he begets not nor is he begotten he's
unique
he is omnipotent he is beyond the
limitations of man
he is beyond the constructs of our
imagination
but he is ever accessible through
sincere supplication
when you call upon him
alone
one God
he is closer to you than your jugular
vein the Quran tells us
he's known by many names and attributes
but his Essence is one he's one God no
human likeness
no human imperfection can be attributed
to him no partners
no image of him can be constructed
and that is God so God represents he is
a feeling of closeness that is
accessible to every human being well
God's Not A Feeling God is known by
names and attributes we call upon God
but
there is certainly a feeling of
closeness when you access him and so I
think the beauty of Islam is that
as perfect as God is described
he's also so accessible to the imperfect
and so the idea of sincere supplication
and connection to him we worship him
alone we call upon him alone there's no
clergy there's no barrier between God
and and us
and that encourages
a sincere devotion and commitment to him
alone and so he is certainly described
Supreme
and God speaks to us through the Quran
and we speak to him through sincere
supplication
and his attributes are the furthest from
us in terms of their perfection but he
is ever close to us through our
supplication through our prayers and
through our connection to him
to open the door to that connection to
have a connection with God how difficult
is that process how difficult was it for
you how difficult is it for the people
that for the many many many Muslims that
you've interacted with
well I think that there are different
layers of difficulty Right There Is the
personal difficulty submitting yourself
to God you know Islam requires a
complete submission to him and
one of the things that happens is that
if we
project
some of our bad experiences with
authority onto our relationship with God
then we immediately perceive him in a
certain way that might not allow us to
gain a closeness to him because maybe we
didn't have the best relationship with
our parents growing up maybe we didn't
have the best relationship with
authority figures in our lives and so
this idea of an ultimate authority to
whom you submit yourself can be very
difficult you know Malcolm X who was one
of the most prominent converts to Islam
in American history talked about the
difficulty of prostration for the very
first time putting your head on the
ground putting your face on the ground
and praying to God is a very humbling
thing submitting all of your Affairs to
him is very humbling
and ultimately you have to relinquish
control and you can't relinquish control
without trust so you have to learn to
trust God to trust God you have to know
him and to know him is to love him and
so
for me personally you know growing up uh
going through certain difficulties
having a sick parent who struggled in
her life with cancer and with Strokes
dealing with racism in south Louisiana
growing up
it was important for me to learn about
God through my difficulties for example
rather than let those difficulties turn
me away from him
many times people put a barrier between
them and God because they can't make
sense of the things that are happening
in their own lives
and so they project anger towards God
and at the same time deny their own
belief in him and do away with this
natural disposition that every one of us
has to believe in him so they're
intellectual barriers certainly there
are experiential barriers
but I think that one of the beautiful
things about Islam is Clarity uh there
is an explanation
for
his existence there's an explanation for
our existence there's an explanation for
the existence of difficulties and trial
and explanation for
the existence of desires and
distractions
and it all comes together so beautifully
and coherently in Islam and so
I think that for many of us we want to
be our own Gods you know and ultimately
we create and fashion gods in ways that
allow us to still be the ultimate
determiners of our own fates of Our Own
story
and that's very unfulfilling when you
fail at your own plan but when you
realize that there is one who was all
knowing
that there is one who is all wise
you actually find peace in submitting
yourself to him and so submitting your
will to him submitting your desires
submitting your own fate to him becomes
actually an experience of Liberation
because you trust the one that you're
submitting to you trust his knowledge
over yours you trust his wisdom over
yours
and that gives you a lot of peace and
then you have direct access to them you
pray to him you call upon him you
supplicate
and
everything in your life suddenly has
meaning you know in our faith
everything is about intention and
there's an intentionality even behind
the most seemingly most mundane actions
a morsel of food in the mouth of your
spouse your family is looked at as a
great charity
the way that you enter into a place and
exit out of a place what foot you step
in what foot you step out with there's
an intentionality there's a word of
remembrance that's spoken
there's a word of Praise before and
after you engage in any action there are
things that you say before you eat
before you sleep there is meaning even
to your sleep one of the great
Companions of the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him he said that I
seek the reward for my sleep just as I
seek the reward for my prayer because
you sleep to refresh yourself so that
you can once again do great things and
the intentionality behind that allows
even the sleep to be rewardable you eat
to nourish yourself so that you can do
great things you seek to be in a
position of Independence and of being
sustained so that you can sustain others
so the prophet peace be upon Him says
for example that the upper hand is
better than the lower hand the upper
hand is the giving hand the lower hand
is the receiving hand so to seek a
position where you can help other people
everything becomes intentional and
there's no such thing as you know
something that is meaningless and
without purpose so every Pursuit is
ultimately a pursuit of God and when you
pursue God sincerely then he rewards you
not just with Paradise in the afterlife
but he rewards you with a great sense of
Serenity and self-satisfaction here